je ne savais pas quel métier je voulais
faire plus tard mais j'étais persuadée
que je voulais travailler pour ma terre
on finoie comment on dit française
j'ai réalisé mes études pendant 5 ans en
métropole et c'est pendant cette période
que je me suis réellement rendu compte
de la chance que j'avais de vivre à
Tahiti par son mot de vie mais aussi ses
richesses comme la nature la rivière la
mer ou encore sa biodiversité ce n'est
donc qu'à partir du Master que j'ai
choisi le domaine de l'environnement car
j'ai oublié même ma pierre à l'édifice
pour préserver toutes ces richesses
après avoir obtenu mon master je suis
tombé au hasard un matin sur un article
du journal disons que l'entreprise
hydroélectrique de Tahiti cherche un
doctorant pour étudier l'impact des
aménagements hydroélectriques sur les
anguilles et en fait pendant mon Master
j'étais déjà interpellée voire intliguer
par cette animal similaire
et surtout que nous avons très peu de
connaissances sur nos espèces de poésie
française dont je me suis tout de suite
dit c'est un nom c'était fait pour moi
donc j'ai postulé et j'ai été choisi le
rêve
quand j'ai commencé je ne comprenais
rien au langage spécifique de
l'hydroélectricité et c'est en
effectuant mes recherches que j'ai pu
acquérir des connaissances dans ce
domaine et que j'ai compris que la
transition énergétique que le sujet de
la transition énergétique était
importante pour une île éloignée telle
que Tahiti et que la dépendance au
pétrole était bien présente à hauteur de
60% minimum par an
donc l'hydroélectricité permet de
produire une grande part d'électricité à
Tahiti environ 30% chaque année pour
seulement 5 vallées aménagées et j'ai
découvert qu'il avait un grand potentiel
pourquoi car à Tahiti nous avons en tout
72 vallées donc 72 grandes rivières ces
rivières sont notre richesse naturelle
car grâce à elle il ne faut pas
l'oublier nous avons nous avons à
profusion l'eau domestique l'eau potable
chez nous dans nos maisons
et en plus on peut produire de
l'électricité avec
mais je trouve qu'on oublie souvent les
rivières par rapport à la mer alors
qu'elle comporte une faune aquatique
dont beaucoup de monde ne connaissent
pas ils ne font pas attention lorsqu'ils
vont dans la rivière comme moi avant
et grâce à cette étude j'ai appris que
la majorité de nos espèces de rivières
sont indigènes c'est-à-dire que c'était
des espèces marines auparavant et
lorsque Tahiti a été créé en plein océan
lorsque nos rivières ont été créés ces
espèces se sont adaptées toutes seules à
nos rivières et n'ont pas été
introduites par l'homme
on dit que ces espèces sont amphis à
lignes c'est à dire que leur cycle de
vie comprend une partie en mer et une
partie en rivière et il y en a 15 trois
espèces d'anguilles une espèce de coco
une espèce de NATO cinq espèces de
chevrettes qui sont des crevettes d'eau
douce et 5 espèces de Gobi dont les
juvéniles sont appelés Ina Atari t
les chevrettes les cocos les gobies se
reproduisent en rivières pendant rivière
et lorsque les œufs vont éclore les
larves vont devoir aller obligatoirement
en mer pour effectuer leur croissance et
devenir des juvéniles ensuite les
juvéniles vont retourner dans la rivière
c'est donc pour cela que les Ina
s'empêcher sans pleine mer soit
l'embouchure et que s'il n'y a pas ce
lien entre la mer et la rivière les
larmes meurent
alors que les anguilles les nataux se
reproduisent en mer mais il faut leur
croissance en rivière
c'est donc pour cela qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir d'aquaculture de toutes ces
espèces
car j'insiste le lien entre la mère et
la rivière et primordiale pour que ces
espèces effectuent leur cycle de vie
mais le cycle de vie de l'anguille est
comme un particulier pourquoi tout
simplement parce que les adultes
reproducteurs vont se reproduire en
plein océan jusqu'à 1000 mètres de
profondeur
ensuite il meurt
mais avant de mourir la femelle va
prendre jusqu'à un million d'oeuf
dont les œufs vont éclore en plein océan
et cela va donner des larves
leptocéphales donc elles sont
transparentes en forme de feuilles et
les nageoires ne sont pas encore formés
donc c'est larves vont emprunter les
courants marins pour arriver jusqu'à nos
rivières et se métamorphoser en juvénile
dans Guy qu'on appelle des civils c'est
civettes transparente m'ont remonter la
rivière ils vont commencer à se
pigmenter donc on commençait à prendre
de la couleur
et vont donc entamer leur étape de
croissance vont passer au stade d'angui
jaune dès qu'il y a du jaune sur une
anguille c'est à dire qu'elle est
toujours en état de croissance par
exemple il y a quelques années nous
avons capturé notre spécimen record de 2
mètres
dans la vallée il y a qui était toujours
jaune
elle n'a pas été domestiquée si elle est
vraiment sauvage ensuite cet anguille
jaune va se métamorphoser en ont dit
argenté lorsqu'elle se sentira prête à
aller se reproduire en mer
sa peau va devenir argenté c'est
nageoire pectorale vont grandir ses yeux
vont grandir vont devenir bleus
donc si un jour vous observez une
anguille argentée aux yeux bleus
s'il vous plaît ne l'empêchez pas à
aller en mer et voudra aller se
reproduire
c'est donc pour cela que l'on dit est un
grand mystère pour les scientifiques
car nous connaissons uniquement le lieu
de reproduction de cette espèce du 19
espèces d'anguilles présentes dans le
monde
par exemple l'anguier européenne
parcourt 6000 km dans la mer des
Sargasses pour aller se recroqueir
incroyable
nous en Polynésie
nous ne connaissons pas le lieu de
reproduction de nos trois espèces
présentes donc ici on pourrait dire
française et il nous manque encore
beaucoup de connaissances à apprendre
sur ces espèces
alors que l'on dit chez nous en
Polynésie française peu plaisantant un
symbole écologique
c'est elle qui est le plus grand
prédateur de nos rivières c'est elle qui
est toute la chaîne alimentaire de la
rivière elle est même cannibale elle se
mange entre elles
on dit en premierifie française qu'une
vivait est en bonne santé s'il y a des
anguilles
c'est aussi un symbole sacré chez nous
on peut unifier français pendant les
gens polynésiennes mais surtout par la
légende de Gina ou du cocotier ou elle
représente la création de la vie par la
pousse du premier cocotier grâce à la
tête d'une anguille et c'est bien grâce
à ces gens qu'elle est très peu
consommée ici en politique française
alors que dans les autres pays elle est
consommée et commercialisée
même dans certains pays elle est classée
en bois de disparition
cet animal me fascine pourquoi c'est ton
poisson et respire par les bronchies
dans l'eau mais elle peut inspirer
également hors de l'eau une dizaine
d'heures
oui j'en ai été témoin donc je vais vous
raconter une petite anecdote au bureau
nous avons un grand aquarium rempli de
poissons de rivière et un matin nous
arrivons au bureau on retrouve une dans
le parking
une autre dans un autre bureau une autre
encore dans un autre bureau
mais comment c'est possible et on s'est
tout de suite dit elles sont mortes à
sécher
donc c'est vrai que là je vous raconte
je vous ai partagé beaucoup de
connaissances beaucoup d'informations
mais c'est vraiment grâce à mon parcours
professionnel que j'ai pu acquérir
toutes ces connaissances et j'en ai
encore d'autres à apprendre et à
découvrir
lorsque j'ai obtenu mon doctorat
l'entreprise m'a engagé en 2018
pour continuer mais le cherche
scientifique jusqu'à aujourd'hui
je suis même sorti de campagne de pêche
aujourd'hui
et je suis là devant vous ce soir
et je continue ce suivi scientifique
chaque année où je m'aperçois que les
vallées aménagées sont vivants et sont
remplis de poisson de rivière les
aliments à passer les aménagements et de
l'eau électrique
et je réalise d'autres actions
environnementales comme la lutte contre
les espèces envahissantes comme la
sensitive géante ou encore la petite
fourmi de feu qui est en fléau chez nous
en Polynésie française
ou encore il y a la mesure des
paramètres physico-chimiques
lors des travaux réalisés dans la
rivière
où je dois vérifier qu'il n'y ait aucune
pollution dans la rivière pour qu'il n'y
ait aucun impact sur les poissons de nos
rivières
et je réalise encore d'autres missions
mais le plus difficile pour moi
a été de faire respecter ce que je
voulais mettre en place dans
l'entreprise pour préserver
l'environnement
mais c'est en partageant mes
connaissances que mes collègues de
travail ont compris pourquoi
il devait le faire pourquoi c'était
important de le faire
cela m'a appelé quand même un an de
faire changer les consciences et depuis
c'est un réflexe automatique d'intégrer
l'environnement dans les travaux
réalisés en valide
donc on peut dire aujourd'hui qu'on peut
faire de l'hydroélectricité qui est une
énergie renouvelable non polluante en
préservant la biodiversité des rivières
de plus l'entreprise a souhaité que je
partage toutes ces connaissances
acquises
auprès du grand public et des scolaires
donc chaque année je passe en plusieurs
écoles qui souhaitent comprendre le
fonctionnement de l'hydroélectricité et
en connaître plus sur la biodiversité de
nos rivières
où j'emmène systématiquement un aquarium
rempli de ses poissons
j'adore ces interventions scolaires car
les enfants sont toujours émerveillés de
voir les poissons de rivière qui n'ont
jamais fait attention lorsqu'ils sont
allés dans la rivière
et c'est un réel échange car il me
partage leurs histoires
il me raconte qu'ils ont des bassins
d'anguilles qu'il les protègent qui ne
jettent pas de cailloux pour les
protéger ou encore ils ont enfin compris
pourquoi les zombies de leur bassin
avait disparu
tout simplement ils étaient contents
qu'elles étaient parties aller se
reproduire
je participe également à plusieurs
forums chaque année comme la fête de
l'énergie la Fête de la Science la
journée de l'eau ou encore le village de
l'environnement où je rencontre des
personnes qui partagent leurs
connaissances dans leur propre domaine
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait un
manque de connaissances nos domaines de
l'énergie et de la biodiversité des
rivières
j'en profite donc pour leur faire passer
un message comme quoi l'électricité on
ne l'a pas comme ça donc la commande
doit il y a des gens qui travaillent
pour et surtout qu'en 2023 il est encore
des personnes qui n'ont pas accès à
Tahiti à l'électricité
de plus je sensibilise également sur
l'importance de nos rivières car je le
répète c'est grâce à elle qu'on a l'eau
domestique et l'eau potable chez nous
dans nos maisons à profusion
ce n'est pas la même chose dans les
atomes
et que ces rivières
jouent un rôle très important dans la
transition énergétique de notre foi
heureusement qu'il y a des entreprises
et des associations
qui réalisent les actions de
préservation de biodiversité de nos
richesses et qui partagent leurs
connaissances car il y a un grand manque
de connaissances de nos richesses ici à
Tahiti
comme tamari
qui lutte contre le blanchissement des
coraux
et qu'il faut même participer la
population en réalisant du bouturage de
corail il y a également
des mano témoins qui préservent les
tortues
qu'il est soigne qu'il les protège
et qui luttent également quand la petite
fourmi de feu qui tue ses oiseaux et
d'autres espèces
il y a aussi fait noir qui s'occupe des
cas du cas des déchets qui est un gros
sujet chez nous pour des petites îles
comme chez nous ils ont même mis en
place un tri des différentes classes de
déchets il y en a encore d'autres que je
remercie pour toutes ces actions de
préservation
donc merci à toutes ces personnes qui
réalisent ces actions pour que nous
polynésiens nous nous rendons compte de
la chance que nous avons et surtout
que nous connaissons mieux notre terre
pour mieux la préserver
j'espère que ces actions
pousseront la population et surtout nos
jeunes
à préserver l'environnement il y a agir
pour la transition énergétique et
écologique de notre finnois
comme on dit les générations futures
sont notre avenir mais comme je dis
toujours nos actions d'aujourd'hui sont
l'héritage de demain